SPEAKER: --a particularly
persuasive story,
and to onboard stakeholders
or other partners,
or actually to make an
effective pitch, why
we need to focus on this
particular area versus another.
So again, implementing
these data-driven decisions
with an eye towards
other skill sets again,
like along the lines
of storytelling.
JENNY OLDFIELD: I think
that's absolutely true.
One of the problems of this
area is that data is complex.
Technology is complex.
It confuses people,
whereas we need
to give vaccinations to a
child is easy to understand.
We need to feed people
is easy to understand.
So there's a challenge to us to
communicate why this matters.
But in terms of people
interested to get involved,
there are so many ways.
And there are a number of
different organizations
that allow you to donate
your time without needing
to be physically in the space,
to do things like playing games
that help identify
malaria through looking
at different sequences to
mapping different areas.
One of the big
problems is that there
are whole parts of the world
that aren't mapped and could
do with being better captured.
So if you only have
a few hours a week,
and you're interested
in this, then there
are many different
ways to get involved.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And to add opportunities,
beyond this area of expertise
question, there's
also opportunities
to participate in the Data for
Good movement through Kaggle
and also just learn
more about data science.
So Kaggle, for those
unfamiliar with the platform,
is a community
platform to actually
problem-solve together, to
use their workbench solution
of kernels to analyze data sets
and actually show your work,
so to speak, as you go
through that analysis,
and also be able to engage
with other members who are
participating on the platform.
Kaggle also launched a series
of Data Science for Good events.
So if you are a data scientist
or burgeoning data scientist,
you can explore those
challenges and put your skills
to work there too.
Another organization that we
have worked with in the past,
and actually presented a webinar
with previously back in--
I think it was
about June or July--
is DataKind.
So DataKind-- they do
a lot of great work.
They have a large--
I think last time I checked
over 18,000 volunteers
as part of their network.
And they actually match pro
bono data scientists, analysts,
designers, et cetera, with
mission-driven organizations
that are facing a particular
data analytics challenge.
So that's another great
way to get involved.
JENNY OLDFIELD: Absolutely.
SPEAKER: And the
partnership, of course.
JENNY OLDFIELD: Yes.
The partnership is
focused on organization.
So I would encourage anyone
working institutionally
who wants to get involved.
But as I mentioned,
many of our partners--
so if you come to
www.data4sdgs.org,
then you can see all of our
partners, and a number of them
focus on individuals and
how they can get involved.
SPEAKER: Yeah, absolutely.
Wonderful.
Well, thank you again
for your time today.
It was great to have
this opportunity
to have Jenny be present and
share the work that she's
doing with the Global
Partnership for Sustainable
Development Data and also
touch on the initiatives
that we launched recently.
Again, those are Data
Solutions for Change
for Nonprofits and Visualize
2030, a data storytelling
contest for students
at the higher ed level.
So with that, stay tuned
for the next session,
and continue to keep up
with Cloud OnAir webinars.
Thank you.
JENNY OLDFIELD: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]